Bowers: So remember, too,
that that was in Java
and it was really quick; there
was no server configuration,
there was very little
development configuration.
Just installed Eclipse
and installed a plug-in
and it was pretty much
ready to go.
Also notice that I didn't
have to write
any JavaScript XHR calls.
That's because I'm using
Google Web Toolkit,
and it'll handle
the communication
between the client
and the server for me.
So what App Engine does
on the back-end
making server-side tasks easier,
Google Web Toolkit
does on the front-end,
making client-side coding
and development easier as well.
So if we can
go back to slides...
[laughter]
So they told me I needed
a marchitecture diagram.
So it's Google Web Toolkit
in the front,
and App Engine in the back.
Now I want to talk
about two features
that are coming up
in Google Web Toolkit.
We're optimistic
that HTML 5 is going to
bring some sanity
to the browser world.
Yet you're still going to
have to develop
for multiple browsers.
Now, Google Web Toolkit's
inherently designed
to work across browsers,
handling the differences
for you.
So you write
your user interface in Java,
and then the compiler
is going to handle the compiling
to the optimized, appropriate
JavaScript-rich environment.
But right now there's a wrinkle
in that development flow.
We encourage people to use CSS
'cause it's a powerful way
to style your apps, but if
you're familiar with this,
you'll also know
it's frustratingly inconsistent.
[applause]
I see some of you relate.
So it's times like these
when you want to use Firebug
to figure out
what the heck's going on.
Now, here's the wrinkle.
Because we have
real time Java debugging
in Google Web Toolkit
using a special browser,
it's meant you had to compile
the JavaScript first,
then take that,
go view that in Firefox,
and then look at Firebug,
and then so we had
an extra step in there.
Well I'm happy to say
in the next version
of Google Web Toolkit
You'll no longer
have to do that.
You'll be able to debug
directly in the browser.
It's also not just Firefox,
it's any browser.
So let me show you a quick demo
of what that looks like.
So I'm gonna go back to
the project that I just created,
and I'm gonna change
the launch configuration
to use the new plug-in.
So we'll take this out here.
So this is gonna start up
the plug-in infrastructure.
And I'm gonna close down nightly
and start up the other version
of Firefox we have here,
'cause that's what my plug-in
is installed on.
Now I can navigate
to my local server.
And you'll notice
that I'm passing in,
uh, special query parameters
so that we know it's coming
from the hosted mode.
And you can see this is the--
the app that I just had,
and so now I can use Firebug
and inspect like--
like you're used to.
Okay, well, that doesn't
seem too special,
but remember that what I have
on the back-end is still Java.
So you can see this is Java
that we're generating here.
I can make that change,
go back to Firefox--
I'm not using
the special browser here--
click "Refresh,"
and then I should be able
to inspect that.
Let's see if we refresh again.
Or sometimes it helps
to restart your server.
So let's do that. All right.
So we've got that running.
And make sure I didn't cache.
So this is going to make the
development cycle a lot faster.
It's also going to work
on multiple browsers as well,
so all the major browsers
have plug-ins.
And there we go.
There we see some changes.
[applause]
And it'll also work
with other plug-ins as well.
Now, I want to talk
about one more feature
that we're really excited about
in the next version
of Google Web Toolkit.
With all this
HTML 5 functionality
you're going to find yourself
writing rich user interfaces.
And if you've built apps
like that before,
really large
JavaScript Ajax apps,
you'll know that your JavaScript
codebase is going to grow,
and it's going to grow a lot.
If we can go back
to slides, please.
It's going to grow a lot
as you add more functionality.
And that in turn means
your users are going to wait,
and they're going to wait,
and they're going to wait
for your application
to finish loading.
So you need a way to split up
all those JavaScript files
across multiple files
so your user
can get started
with your application
without having to wait for it.
However, manually
splitting JavaScript
can be very tedious.
You have to get
the dependencies correct,
uh, it takes a long time,
and you really--
it's not something you wanna do
on a Friday night.
So that's why the next version
of Google Web Toolkit
we're gonna
help you out with that,
and do it for you
with something called,
"developer-guided
code splitting,"
also known as runAsync.
Now with runAsync, what you do
is specify in your code
somewhere that you're willing
to accept a short pause
in exchange for the compiler
being able
to functionally fragment
your codebase.
So what this means
is I can download code
after the initial download.
Imagine you have
a settings page, it's not real--
uh, it's rarely used,
not used on startup at least.
Well, there's
no reason to download
that code with your
initial download.
Instead you'd set
a runAsync split point,
then allow that code to download
in the background
after your user
is up and running.
Okay, you're saying, "Andrew,
that's great in theory,
but does it really work?"
Well, I'd like to leave you
with some metrics
from a real world application
that's using runAsync.
This is a application
we'll talk more about tomorrow.
This is a graph
during development
of the size
of the JavaScript codebase.
So it quickly grew
to 1.4 megabytes
as they added
more functionality to the UI.
So that's--that's a lot of code
to download on initial download.
Now, after runAsync,
the initial download
was decreased to 200k,
which can then be decreased
another 80k--to about
another 80k when you gzip it.
So 1.4 megabytes
to 200 kilobytes.
So it's about a 7x decrease.
It's going to load a lot faster.
And the best part
is they didn't have to worry
about the dependencies
themselves.
The compiler looked
at their codebase
and handled all that for them.
So these are just a few of
the features that we're adding
to Google Web Toolkit.
We're gonna be talking
a lot more about the future
and the present
with both App Engine
and Google Web Toolkit
over the next few days,
so please stop by and join us.
Thank you.
[applause]
Thanks.
Gundrota: Great job, guys.
And as you can see, these are
the URLs where you can go
to learn more or attend
any of the sessions.
Of course we are very,
very happy at Google
to see the developer
adoption of Google services.
You go to a webpage and you see
someone who's incorporated
Google YouTube, or Google News,
or Google Video,
or even Google Search
on their page,
and it delights us.
You know, we have over 60 APIs
that we make available,
uh, to developers.
In fact, we're very proud
to announce today
that we have crossed
the 4 billion API threshold.
That's 4 billion API calls
every day
coming in to Google.
That's even a big number for us.
And so thank you
for your support,
thank you for, uh, enhancing
your apps with Google services.
Of course, we're not satisfied.
We wanna do more to--
to make your web apps better
and make the web even richer.
And we looked at one of our
most successful models.
And that's AdSense.
There are literally
hundreds of thousands of sites
that use AdSense.
And they get those Google ads
on their page by nothing more
than including
a little bit of JavaScript.
And so we asked ourselves,
why couldn't we
take that approach
for everything we were doing?
Why not make our other services
that easy
to incorporate
into your applications?
To demonstrate a brand-new
developer product for you,
I'd like to invite up
DeWitt Clinton
to walk you through that.
DeWitt, please. Welcome.
Clinton: Hey, thank you, Vic.
[applause]
Hi.
Today I'm very pleased
to introduce
Google Web Elements.
Google Web Elements
bring Google products
to your website using simple
copy and paste.
We were inspired
by the embeddable YouTube video
and AdSense,
and asked ourselves,
could we apply this approach
to more products?
Today I'm going to demonstrate
adding Google News
and Google Maps,
and Google Search
to a website using
Google Web Elements.
Let's get started.
Here's a simple website
we put together.
Standard two-column layout like
something you'd find on Blogger,
or WordPress, or your own site.
It looks pretty good,
but I think we can
make it more dynamic.
I'd like to pull in, uh,
headline news from Google News,
and I'll do that
with a Google Web Element.
I go to google.com/webelements,
and I select the "News" element.
And here I can choose
from headlines from technology,
sports, politics,
or enter my own.
I'll enter "Google."
And I'll fit it to my site.
And I copy the code,
and I go to the HTML of my site,
and find the right place.
and I hit "paste."
When I go back
to the page and refresh,
Google News is already live.
I'd like to add now a map
to Moscone
and the developer conference.
So I go to
google.com/webelements,
I go to the "Maps" element,
I type in, "Moscone Center."
And we're here for Google I/O.
And I like the terrain view.
And again, I copy the code,
I go to my template,